good morning everyone my name is David
Ellwood I'm the Dean here at the John F
Kennedy School of Government and welcome
to the John F Kennedy jr. forum it is my
very great honor to have you all here
today for a special public address by
she's all by she's obey the Prime
Minister of Japan welcome I would like
to acknowledge a number of our
distinguished guests in the audience
ambassador Caroline Kennedy Jack Kennedy
/ Berg and the Consul General of Japan
Tom comedian oh please give him a mohawk
let me also thank the director Maggie
Williams IP directory Maggie Williams
staff of the Institute of Politics and
the office of university marshal for
making this all possible before
introducing everyone I do want to make
one quick announcement which I often
make which is the simple rules of the
road here at that genican a junior form
we have remarkable speakers from around
the world who come here including
today's speaker the rules are very
simple
all speakers must take free and
unfettered questions from the audience
and in exchange the audience allows the
speaker to speak without interruption or
distraction those are the simple rules
those who cannot abide by those rules
will ask to leave and I'm sure at
today's program we'll go terrifically
well in a moment I'm going to turn the
program over to Joan I and I want to
thank Joe for being here today
especially since he just arrived this
morning at 6 a.m. on a flight from Asia
so it's a true true service Joe is the
University Distinguished Service
professor and former dean of the Kennedy
School he really is one of the most
remarkable international relations of
his generation scholars of his
generation he's at his ideas including
soft power are among the most important
and influential ideas that affect
governments around the world not
surprisingly he's been recognized as one
of the top scholars and many many
journals and just this November the
Emperor of Japan conferred the order of
the Rising Sun Gold and Silver Star in
recognition of Jonah's contribution of
the
and of studies on japan-us security and
the promotion of mutual understanding
between Japan the United States he is an
ideal moderator for today's session
before Jo takes over the program though
it's my distinct pleasure to welcome
back Caroline Kennedy who serves as the
ambassador of the United story pan and
has done so since 2013 this is simply
the latest chapter in a remarkable story
of service and inspiration she has
worked as a lawyer author editor she's
authored and co-authored books about
constitutional issues such as the Bill
of Rights and privacy preserving
anthologies and poems and sand photos
ambassador Kennedy has been dedicated to
public service throughout her life
whether it's serving as a chief
executive of the Office of Strategic
partnerships in New York City the
president the director of the John F
Kennedy Library Foundation and I see
Heather Campion has joined us here in
her role leading that effort and we're
especially proud that she has served and
serves as the chair of the senior
Advisory Committee here at the Institute
of Politics in many ways and that
ambassador Kennedy truly has been an
ambassador to us all for a very long
time to do without further ado
ambassador Kennedy
good morning Thank You Dean Elwood for
that very very generous biographical
introduction and it's great to be back
here at the Kennedy School the Institute
of Politics and I'm also grateful to
Professor Nye for his encouragement and
wise counsel during my time as US
ambassador to Japan
it's wonderful to be here when my mother
and uncles created this institution as a
living memorial to my father they
imagine days like this when global
leaders both men and women would engage
students on the critical issues of the
day and that that engagement would
inspire the students to enter public
life committing themselves to public
service I'm also happy to be back in
this forum which bears my brother's name
and carries on his deep belief in
involving young people in politics I'm
happy to be here with my son Jack I used
to get the brown perspective from John
now I get the Yale perspective from Jack
above all I'm honored this morning to
say a few words about Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a the Prime Minister is one
of the most dynamic and effective
political leaders on the world stage
today he has sought to redefine Japan
the global citizenship for the 21st
century he's undertaking a far-reaching
effort to revitalize Japan's economy and
address the challenging and changing
regional security environment indeed the
Prime Minister is a once-in-a-generation
leader at a once-in-a-generation moment
for the us-japan alliance as President
Obama rebounds his US foreign policy
towards Asia
he has no stronger partner than Prime
Minister Abbey who welcomed the
president to Japan last spring on a
critically important state visit and the
president is looking forward to
receiving the prime minister in
Washington this afternoon he will be the
first Japanese Prime Minister to address
a joint session of Congress and there is
of course a lot of interest in what he
has to say during my service in Japan
I've been inspired by Prime Minister
Abe's willingness to address debate the
difficult issues and by his
determination to
achieve real results finally my family
and all of us here are deeply honored
that he has come to Boston as the first
stop on his official visit that he took
the time to visit the Kennedy Library
last night and begins as his start week
by addressing us here this morning at
the Kennedy School Thank You mr. prime
minister
Thank You ambassador Kennedy and it's
nice to have you back here let me say
what a pleasure it is for all of us here
at the Kennedy School to be able to
welcome Prime Minister Shinzo AVI
to our midst for many years American
policymakers in Washington would
complain that they couldn't remember the
name of the Japanese Prime Minister
because it changed every six or 12
months no longer everybody in Washington
knows the name Shinzo Bobby indeed when
I've been in Tokyo people tell me this
is one of the strongest Prime Minister's
Japan has had it's certainly in this
century but in the last half of the last
century he was first Prime Minister in
2006 at that time he was the youngest
Prime Minister the first Prime Minister
born after World War two he was elected
in 2012 and reelected by a landslide in
2014 so nobody is going to forget the
name of this Japanese Prime Minister but
I should add one final detail before
inviting him to speak I can't think of
any other Japanese prime minister who
stood before the United Nations General
Assembly and said we have to do more for
the role of women in Japan and in the
world this is quite a tribute for the
man who is going to speak to us today so
welcome to the Kennedy School prime
minister opping
thank you very much for your wonderful
introduction ambassador Kennedy you've
been so nice to start with the mega
quake that hit Nepal has caused a
tremendous damage and many lives were
lost let me extend my heartfelt
condolences to the victims my heart and
prayer my country has already know to
provide medical support and support for
their reconstruction good morning folks
I am very pleased so many of you have
joined us today thanks of course the
professor I am keen to know what is of
interest to those of you in the
Cambridge community I'm looking forward
to taking your questions I have actually
two cabinet ministers who are product
Yasu he Sachi Ozaki Health Labor and
Welfare Minister and yoshimasa Hayashi
Agriculture Forestry and Fisheries
Minister are both pushing forward in
their respective fields momentous
reforms that happen only once in decades
in fact and pushing forward major
reforms not only whatever economic
rationale there may be no reform
succeeds without first putting your
political classes elaborately into court
by political process I mean the
relationship between the Parliament and
the cabinet between the ruling party and
the opposition and between the
government and the people especially
stakeholders and the government and the
press
no reform is achievable unless you
adequately manage those relationships in
many cases people that are pro-reform
constitute a majority they are a silent
majority vested interests in contrast
readily find opportunities to raise
their concerns reform concerns your
political capital history tells us that
in my country one single administration
deals with at the most one or two reform
agendas meaning all that not
understanding
I have tenaciously engineered a
succession of the reforms coming one
after another and I will be fearless
going forward why do I say it is because
now more than any time before I believe
there is in Japan among its people a
strong and growing desire to pursue
reforms we've had prolonged deflation
demand in the private sector has gone
down as a result so have private savings
given to our aging demography which has
worsened the economy's macro balance my
role in these circumstances is to lead
the nation to think of itself once again
as the little engine that could ozzie
conic economics tells you for us to grow
our economy in Japan there is simply no
getting around increasing our labor
productivity whether my reforms are
about engaging more female labor
infusing into Japan more foreign capital
and knowledge or the TPP all of them are
focused on a single target namely
revamping our way of doing things and
making innovation flourish by changing
diehard business
it's it is my desire to faster young men
and women who envisaged their future in
Japan with greater confidence these
young people will make the economy
stronger take on global issues and as a
result increase the nation's value as
part of a virtuous circle that whole
process
well surely benefit the United States
and the countries of Asia a stronger
more reliable Japan is also in the
interest of the u.s. as it pursues its
policy of rebalancing and I bust
alliance between the u.s. and Japan is
in the interest of the region and of the
world
I believe what comes to your mind when
you think of global issues Ebola climate
change the status of women in developing
countries we can multiply the added
value we bring to all of those areas
through Japan and the u.s. joining hands
in technique those challenges together
with Professor a marquee ascend and
others my country developed and spread
the concept of human security the
essence of human security holes that you
must empower each and every individual
in order to win the battle over poverty
human security also holds girls
education dear when first lady Michelle
Obama was in Japan just recently we
announced that we would include the
education of girls in our shared agenda
Japan and the US are also advancing
their cooperation against
in the Philippines and other Southeast
Asian countries for instance the US and
Japan are working together to build
local capacity for disaster relief and
disaster reconstruction the list
I hold abused time has come for the
us-japan alliance to derive a value
through our struggles with global issues
before I conclude let me and to my
delight some polls of late ranked Tokyo
among the most beautiful cities in the
world Tokyo on a host city for the 2020
Olympics and Paralympics will become a
place even more open toward the rest of
the world and all throughout Japan we
will find many other places hidden gems
if you like awaiting your visit Japan
right in the middle major reforms is now
making I dare say a coup wantem Philippe
please to come and see it for yourself I
also want more students from Japan to
come to Harvard if I may say it again in
closing reform never comes without
resistance there will always be pressure
from society to suppress it still once
you have reached a decision after of
course having given it rigorous but you
must carry through on it reflecting on
that as my own responsibility I was led
to remember what JFK left us what is
leadership all about a young JFK
answered that in the expression grace
under pressure that's what I too hope to
carry forward ladies and gentlemen I
will stop here now and take your
questions
thank you again soon I permit these
arrangements today
Thank You Prime Minister it's now time
for Q&A we have three simple rules in
addition to the basic rules that Dean
Elwood expressed one is when you go to
one of the microphones there two on the
floor here and two in the balconies when
you go to one of the microphones and
queue up and ask a question please
identify yourself
that's rule number one rule number two
is there's one question per customer and
it should be short less than a minute a
quick short question and rule number
three is that a question
ends with a question mark there's only
one speech we've already heard it so
what we want to hear now are questions
so mr. prime minister if you would take
some questions and we will have
consecutive translation with the
questions regarding mr. my class ready
Akane sorry mr. BALCO Dean if that's Ari
Messina I'm sorry about Scott Desdemona
toki niwa go see dr. Mao Asada Sakura
nice name it mostest not dude tomorrow
night oh you got the tea miss Akane
sustained meet Samara
small a question mark about the class I
thought it's the most fit you thought I
target Escarra speakers as me a straw
stick the psycho you gotta sit there on
the idea semester let me start to the
left he thought you got got him in
myself mr. prime minister my name is
Alex Jurgen I'm a joint student in the
Harvard Kennedy School in Harvard
Business School joint program thank you
very much for speaking with us today
my question is on US Japan energy
cooperation and could you talk about the
role of US energy exports to Japan both
economically and also in terms of the
broader strategic interests of the
United States and Japan and the broader
Asian region hey I would tell that
because I must have a gamma Kennedy
School thought or business is good I
thought oh do honey egg thing
Seamus no energy yo a new entry tonight
800 minus ETA no energy no oh man they
know or type koremasa no America a new
home you know or energy you know Canton
Mata Syndicate Akina consent so you can
think America and you know are you a
psychic ena same tactic in a conscience
it's enough that he treated thank you
attack a battle - I knew it - are you
mother any you know somebody not data
danger contentious Liberty hey Thomas in
Japan what is accounted for 30% of our
energy that is a nuclear power plants
have now all had have stopped operations
and when it comes to hydro power or
solar power such renewable renewable
forms of energy account for less than
10% percent per second in do to you Tony
another like a day hey Harry massacre
they said you know oak a matter ha it
doesn't all quality hey makutano
it happens so 90% are accounted for by
fossil fuels and a large part of oil and
a large part of gas is such that we are
dependent on the Middle East day a big
coconut oil shale gas LNG or new
technically no never no no they need to
achieve a hadouken II and thickness so
energy supply in Japan would become very
much stable if there is a import of
shale gas or LNG from the United States
domain Coco Dada
crannis Astacio Gaston know a nigga or
shake that antigone so stay yes we need
Undertaker's to my dog
and so we want to see an increase in
supply of a shale gas from the United
States which is an ally to our country
and if you could supply it to us in a
stable manner and at a cheap price
thank you me know who doesn't
good morning Prime Minister my name is
David Rhodes and I'm a first year Master
of Public Policy here at the Kennedy
School and my question for you is what
steps do you think Japan can still take
to reduce regional tensions within Asia
Pacific kokyo or say no shoes you know
or it's in a no org actually they were
saying yeah general Garre seeks Tokina
at him saw or can wear a suit emini it
all use them for new homework tour you
know they soak up any power tsukino
Tyson Tyson okay naka de hielo condition
I am you own arginine can still get a my
master based on deep remorse F of
regarding World War two Japan has spent
the seventy years after the war steadily
treading the path of a peace-loving
nation Maggiano's Hasan Akane so no II
mean no to my stay as young heart any
duty which takes to heart overall
columnist
Susan you nigga Mahatma staccato Yoda
Tito teach Eva and desert you can get
enough model venomous and we have made
efforts to a spur development in Asia I
believe that the stability in the region
would come about through respective
countries developing holiday agenda no
Johanna treated a re mascara mascara you
do sue McCain John Hancock st Medusa not
my dad mistake
Yashiro Isana no ho sang with a guy
called a midden audience ooh cool
emotions are hot puddings
to us address the present situation we
cannot condone the change of status quo
through coercion and intimidation at the
shangri-la a dialogue I stated three and
proposed three principles Lancaster
suited noir a I hold mottos a
de-iced joystick to dress the first
principle is that State shall make and
clarify their claims based on
international law yeah
ikkaku homogenize the second is that
states shall not use force or coercion
in trying to drive their claims Mendoza
he wanted me here calculate extremes and
the third principle is that should
problems arise states are seek to settle
disputes by peaceful means
Acevedo na jaana finito a detective he
could only hear it soon as ya know whom
you owe my son here won over me
maja a new monistic want a mini
Argentina Chile of course stick to that
one you never thought about terms all of
the participating nations were able to
see eye to eye on this and agreed to
these principles in any case I should
like to make Asian countries the Asian
region the ocean of peace and the ocean
of our prosperity and to this end that
we should like to cooperate with the
countries in Asia but the Nippon to seem
more mature yeah Cancun's I didn't
realize any it was honey the course
darkness and Japan itself will make
efforts to improve relations with China
and the Republic of Korea we turned to
the left balcony
good morning Prime Minister Ave my name
is Anna coral and I'm a sophomore in the
college here at the IOP we promote and
encourage young people to engage in
politics and public service with the
understanding that our generation is the
future how do you see the future of
politics and how does our generation
play into that I know Anna corundum is
the prominent diagonal
say mrs. Connell diachrony okie monster
say G re wa koko services ninja turtle
you cantata here and so they are in a
state or you must it's all right now
series in it sweetie
it's a state so in your care I can say
that I know oh you're going to it again
cos theta about - hey Missoni mama dada
like i said i'll aha not like animus the
younger generation indeed shoulder the
future
hey what's more for monarch item and
understand a mostly knee Hado could you
you know I think of myself as being
young but I'm already a sixty man upon
you - aha a tone and a maken dogma my
become mostly so not illness I'm a Jew
has any scientists have we I will be
reducing the age of eligibility for
voting to 18 years in the United States
this has already happened a 1904 to come
in eat them all at I do know she
community mother's name
so the hottest a high-stress eager so no
oh hey Lincoln yeah II do know how me
know she conveniently Disney did you
touch any attacks the Dajjal to Potomac
I mean a song cause of all can I hit a
Madonna get about nine homers and
whether it's a pension or medical
services and the schemes and
institutions are for providing these I
believe the subject of interest that to
the younger generation is whether they
could receive the benefits in terms of
insurance and in terms of a pensions and
medical care and whether the system will
stay intact matter like annoyed kwinto
kwinto no a continue into a district
nee-sama sabana Hidayah for booted
barring a haha Damascus
Akashi IDO genius new high static
acoustic guitar I know go Kyoto tick
what Ronnie DeFeo Semitic I also mean to
me I'd take a clue - wah-wah - do I -
Thomas are not effective
I stupid Sanada manasa a Ukrainian in
Pune criminal program or so mental mercy
in pornography more about those who may
second did it to my door right now in
diplomacy relationships between
countries are such that sometimes there
are challenges but I believe that the
young people have an opportunity to
resolve misunderstandings and to
understand each other and to recognize a
diversity in that sense I wish to
welcome young people from Asia and the
United States to come to Japan and also
for Japanese our students to go to
Harvard and to go elsewhere in the world
hello Prime Minister my name is Joseph
Cho and I'm a sophomore here at the
college I'd like to thank you once again
for coming to speak to us today I
apologize in advance if my question
comes off as provocative but it has to
do with the topic that weighs heavily on
my heart as someone with ties to South
Korea I know that the issue of comfort
women has been a source of contention
between my country and yours there are
solid proof showing that the Japanese
government and military were directly
involved in the comfort women system and
Japan has even formally apologized for
this in the 1993 kono statement so my
question is in the face of all these
facts do you still deny the Japanese
government's explicit involvement in the
subjugation of hundreds of thousands of
women into coerced sexual slavery thank
you Joseph so there was I must hone oh I
died happy Nina and there was I miss it
it took the towhead stickiness I assume
only ecomaster emotionally I notice now
attacks to satanic agitated among those
I must concur Cooney it's not hiding I
do show you a text or a test image they
were Yahoo no Oman take Oliver new home
well become captain either he Tony
no tenth or not they do Monday the
services the Katai Yakko God and human
no safe food so stay
stato you so comedy it's the same she
accuses a new corner did so-called a
habit oh oh you quoted a youngster demo
oh sorry demo Oh safe because I kind of
startled you ketosis oh ah stay in a
cenote Sokka a sustained Antonito you
Joe Sena say taketori toast a chaos ate
a guinea mrn cost 800 you go dr. Nasir
no debts oka my yahoo and I'm tuturro
December balance is not destiny hint
segata sanshiro' segata Hanna Pato Amado
him Adam oh what a souvenir AHA it Amos
and so normally were late today
no Hosono Muto hey Cody raha nothing
when it comes to the comfort women issue
my heart aches when I think about those
people who were victimized by human
trafficking and who were subjected to
immeasurable pain and suffering beyond
the description on this score my feeling
is no different from my predecessor
Prime Minister's McConnell Dawa Hani
cetera
ekishu suited to a modern
anti-commercial teach the heartily there
was a massacre
Mukunda honeymoon wa palma de a yes no
kata not majestic you say no whole
hunting cara mia' get a master several
times in the past I have had the
occasion to mention that I will uphold
the corner of statement
so from such a standpoint Japan has made
various efforts from the perspective of
offering realistic relief for the
comfort women manager say Geneva my soda
be from saga Alberto Hojo say no or
Dinkin Mira
of Kaka who kills K right haha did I the
more animated initiative Sakura so you
sit in eastern and I design us turn
Canadians in the 20th century we have
seen history where once conflict arises
women's human rights and honor are
deeply wounded we had such a history in
the 21st century we should not make this
history which is akin to the 20th
century
codeine soaked I knew it
Tokido no or sticky body that's the next
accompany any promised us a state ID mr.
Sahay even women Oh Hajime chose to do a
cocktail Tecna communicate as master
anything you name near a scenic man does
not surely open eye he's in juvenile you
are insane Jackman DiNozzo
what did you say taniwha just say no
honking yeah I'm ready
thinking to deny a second is ticked
it's you kitty you're almost a hippo
monotone they start at the UN General
Assembly last year in order to eliminate
sexual violence in conflict situation I
promise that Japan would stand at the
forefront leading the international
society the International framework
beginning with you and women entities to
which Japan has contributed in 2014 to
the tune of 12 million dollars and in
2015 decision has me been made to
contribute approximately 22 million
dollars and so we have very resolutely
determined that in the 21st century
women's human rights should not be
violated
good morning mr. prime minister
my name is true coil and I'm a junior at
Harvard College I'm from Mumbai
my question is specific to BRIC nations
of Brazil Russia India and China what
role do you envision Japan playing both
economically and geopolitically with
regards to these countries I know you
share a very special bond with our prime
minister mr. Modi and so just curious
about that see II know Sunday no
although I do that was I must we
recorded every Russia in doe or - no
Kuni can stay and you know case I take
in each say Hawks technique don't you
acquire your capacity you gotta go so no
no - okay token II what actual Mumbai
director in Bosnia what does she know
okay Nina so Oh Modi so Tata hey it's
Kasey Kahne you even leak a story must
you can write I don't know it was enough
for my bricks no for mackaninee my
gender not so did I hey kadai oh ho what
a massacre I think I know kids I spotted
it's not how I cannot see also an
opening he Mathilde humans the BRICS
countries are such that each have their
own specific issues but they have the
potential to be the traction for the
world economy being the drive for the
world economy
my surname homo homini Punto Brava
attend totally knee hit an engaging
narrative
Temari you cannot until home we must
imitate a technical nanny hey Takumi
host a massacre upon a canal or canal
cuckoo so they're not extremist a last
year hide the occasion to visit Brazil
we have in Japan strong ties with Brazil
there being many Brazilians of Japanese
origin and so we have a friendly
relationship they are beset with
economic difficulties at the moment but
I am convinced that Japan will overcome
these
sorry Brazil overcome these issues
melosa honey hey madam Xterra Griner ha
know who invented as I see a gorgeous
coach technical new it here Tecna access
doors to my title here members with
regard to Russia I hope that at all
costs they would reach agreement on the
issue of the Ukraine and bring about a
peaceful resolution
majnu a new plaintiff of rojava
sanguine origin a mother Heba joy
gratitude society nitrogen to the was a
Mossad a and - wha
idly a tile Smith also contained a very
much anger he was because they don't go
Semitic that at the same time
seventy years after world war two we
have not concluded a peace treaty with
Russia and so I should like to somehow
continue a dialogue with mr. Putin and
I'm sure it's not easy but I should like
to make an effort to conclude the peace
treaty achieving to tell my son to open
a hard era any point second to 1000 th
and start on things as for China the
development of China is a major positive
for Japan and the world
my name is Natalia Natalia to do for the
magnet I stay Nepal to me as an open
open you cannot do no more study good
Nicki no katadyn see the Mossad ends at
the same time
China's conduct in the South China Sea
as well as the East China Sea such that
Japan and many countries in Asia are
concerned the same goes for militarism
displayed by China as I see the
cheekiness Aquino doctor stay Maha Tecna
tight oh ho ho symmetry he was taking
that title or motto media tonight I know
him as a responsible major power in the
region
I hope sincerely that
it would find a peaceful answer to its
challenges so stay in dough dilemma saga
aside I know home in Chicago window San
Giovanni
it to hunt any state that emims a mother
here sure my sembalun ahead and it's
your semester in anti gosh no goddamn
much nobody mow the hay holy most what
is shown or material adidas piatas
Mahindra McCarthy who had this day as
for India it is the largest democratic
nation and I wish to see relations are
strengthened between India and Japan
Prime Minister Modi has come to Japan
and I have had the occasion to engage in
talks with him at multilateral fora many
times and under a strong leadership of
Prime Minister Modi I hope that India
will achieve a very robust development
and I have great expectations of this
nasty on the official new item on mind
atomic until toka state that an idea and
not only in the area of the economy I
wish to strengthen bilateral relations
with India in the field of security as
well
right for me this is unfortunately going
to have to be our last question
thank you so much Prime Minister Abe a
it's such an honor and a pleasure to
hear you speak here
my name is seats ago fart I'm a senior
at Harvard College studying economics
and my question is the following so in
your speech you talked a lot about your
goal your overall mission of elevating
the status of women in Japanese society
and in the work force which is next
linkle
but surely of course you will admit that
it's still a challenge right now
according to statistics from The
Economist only about 1% of senior
executives in the Japanese workforce are
women and owned and sort of the the
female representation in the Japanese
Parliament is still in the teens so I'm
wondering sort of goals aside can you
lay out specific things and actions that
you have done in office or continuing to
do in office to try to change that
thank you and how about on Sunday no
kids on day one of this mr. McCotter
take away the animal stuff see all my
stuff in my house just say no sekai New
York area Tsukuba okay let's see your
minute oh you got on it's a state again
a side mr. teller Disney Elko Nevada
Nevada hide her top you know more time
assisting ago this is movement America
so economy store no tokiyori Moscow or
Tokyo company Twitter it'll say we pass
in tariqa sustain a companion guru just
say no no mr. Onizuka night oh you
promise this Cara Moo puris at the with
a good night a guinea nano stay around
ahsoka so stay a corrector I adore you
photostated ahsoka enough Oh mothers me
Alaska Alaska Dakota passed a total
mistake a calming coca-cola me no syeonu
ETA Joe say no ho Macondo coho say Rojo
family actual the family yo ma - si si
Oh Massa better not show de estado de
aqui esta vez I am doing new things
beginning with areas where I can make
advances with regard to the civil
servants I have given a goal of making
30% of executive executive position
women and candidates to be hired and
many most of all of the ministries have
cleared this goal a 30% of candidates
for executive positions in government
but actually mother ha Justino Coconino
Carlos cleanser masca - no - no idea
next chakra emits no hot you next chakra
are like the hey Ali massacre absolutely
not
storage economy no just tacky hey hey no
Yakushima the semester
indeed the number of women
parliamentarians in the diet or the
Parliament is indeed very small in terms
of number but when the Abbaye government
was elected there are three major
positions in the party a Liberal
Democratic Party and the two of these
are three positions are now filled by
women
Akira Yamaoka local state is a helmet
and giorgio a doctor named candy Yaquina
huzzah or Oakland candy - Jimmy Harris
and Eska absurdly knowledge they need
ink and in candy Hakata gmail famous and
we have cooperation from the economic
circles as well among the listed
companies in they have taken the 60
years to have 90 women directors but
with the election of the a Bay
Administration in two years that we have
achieved 180 so in Oita it's not Tony
ominous new social all attached no ho
diverter stage or Sega I told your
signal you enjoyed your news 9 actually
we can't want anything so in that sense
I must be prepared for a women rival
competing with me maja
Oh Pinocchio Dominus knee a shock I says
I could turn after a Joe Sega help Tony
hey material oh no thought you said you
got ticked oh you need your modem
eternal optimist and I would hope that
the companies have the awareness that
they are hiring women not because of
social policy but because hiring women
would improve the corporate performance
and I would hope that they would have
such a recognition hey yo como el
nordeste Merryman Brazos kimochi demon
blaster nasty demon brothers and sisters
I often say that had the Lehman Brothers
have been there Lehman Brothers &
Sisters they would still be around
please join me in thanking Prime
Minister Ami
very good
you